Thank You Nova sorry speaking about
explicit to source extractors and
resilient functions and joint work with
David Zuckerman all right so as we all
know here in this workshop randomness is
important and we are trying to read
reduce it so it's widely used in a bunch
of areas in computer science like
algorithms cryptography distributed
computing data structures and many more
right for example in cryptography it's
actually essential that you use random
as well you need the secret keys are
uniformly random actually because there
are many easy attacks if there is some
structure known about the keys that you
are using in your crypto systems whether
there is actually research which shows
that for basic cryptographic tasks like
big commitment schemes and many others
you actually need uniform and
uncorrelated bits even high entropy
sources are not enough for carrying out
these tasks and there are papers which
actually break such cryptosystems if you
just use high entropy sources so the
question now is how do you get access to
these armed random bits well there are
various ways of collecting entropy from
various sources like there are software
solutions like you use operating system
interrupts keyboard activities of users
and things like that um most
sophisticated techniques some require
you know access to some physical sources
of randomness and typically what happens
is there's these things collect some
entropy but they are far from producing
uniform purely random bits at best what
the produce is correlated bits which
contains some amount of uncertainty or
entropy in them and the task here is to
use some kind of a deterministic
procedure or some kind of a function to
extract purely random bits out of these
for all kinds of applications
for a simple example well could think of
a stream of independent bits where each
bit takes 0 with probability P and 1
with probability 1 minus P so these kind
of sources were studied by 491 in 1950s
and it developed a simple extractor for
this the idea is you pair bits from this
stream if it's 01 you are put 0 if it's
10 you output 1 as you repeat and it's
fairly easy to show that he'll produce
almost uniform bits using this procedure
and there have been many generalizations
considered one specific example is
sources generated by constant size
Markov chains plum give various results
on such X Factor's but the question here
is how do you model a week random source
so in the boot camp david give a bunch
of lectures where you motivated these
things and quickly go over how to model
a week source so the first first item
could be just to use Shannon entropy but
it turns out that since in this setting
you get just one sample from the source
and you want to apply some function to
know extract bits from it this is not
strong enough and the problematic
distribution is suppose you have a
distribution d which with very high
priority always outputs are fixed string
say it outputs the all 0 string so 0
power n is the all 0 string and with
probability 0 point 0 1 it's uniform on
all n bits right so a calculation shows
that this is a distribution with linear
entropy which is very high but if you
just get one sample from it you cannot
you overwhelmingly always see the all 0
string and you cannot expect to extract
random bits from this so what we need
actually is a stronger notion of entropy
which is a strict a notion of entropy
which is min entropy where for a
distribution X you look at the maximum
weight it places at any point in its
support and there is a suitable
normalization that you do and an easy
calculation actually shows that the mint
p of this distribution d it says it's
very small it's order one so it's okay
that we are not able to extract from
such distributions so some more
intuition about min entropy will be
dealing with n comma K sources so these
are distributions on n bits right it's
it's distributions on n bits with min
entropy at least K what this means is
that X places fit at most to power minus
K on any input in its support all right
and a special case is if X is uniform on
some unknown subset of size to partly
right so it takes each element in this
set with probability to power minus K so
by definition it's an n comma k source
and this work offshore and goldrick
which actually shows that for most you
can show that any general n comma k
source is a convex combination of these
you know flat sources so it's enough to
deal with the special case of sources
which are uniform on some unknown subset
all right so n comma K sources are
distributions on n bits with minute of
it is K the first definition of a
randomness extractor would be a
deterministic procedure that extracts a
uniform that's from any n comma k source
so for this talk I will try to just
focus on extracting one bit but the
general goal is to extract more bits out
of it however it turns out that there
cannot exist a single extractor for the
class of all n comma n minus 1 sources
all right so let me focus that you would
want one extractor to work for any n
comma K so so you do not get to see the
source and then design your extractor
you are just given a guarantee of that
your source has some amount of entropy
right and
there's a lemma which shows that even if
your source thus the source ID you start
off with has entropy n minus 1 which is
almost full you cannot design a single
extractor that works for all these and
it's a pretty simple exercise to show
this all right so clearly we need more
assumptions and there have been various
directions taken over the past few
decades so one is suppose whatever your
extractor now has access to more
independent bits another direction which
has been really successful is suppose
you want to extract from a source which
is on n bits but now you have a few
helper seeds to extract from this and
these helper bets are uniform and
independent and it's much shorter than
the N comic asos think of these helper
seed as soft side say order log in
further other directions are suppose you
have just one source but now you have
some assumptions on the source for
example say the source is sampled by an
algorithm which has limited memory which
is which is which captures many natural
sources or if it's uniform on some
unknown a fine subspace or simpler
source is say bit fixing sources but
it's a distribution on n bits where you
know that some unknown subset of say K
bits are uniform an independent and the
remaining bits may or may not depend on
these uniform pants and I'll not go into
this but designing such extractors for
all these classes of sources have had
various applications in complexity
theory cryptography for example for
proving lower bounds in for showing
formula lower bounds as well so it's
good to design explicit extractors
that's the message from the slide all
right so now let's go to the focus of
the stock which is to source extractors
so the setting is the following you have
so curly brackets 0 comma 1 power m is
the set of all n bit strings so you have
two sources XY which are independent and
then comma K
sources so there are distributions on n
bits and they have been entropy at least
K which means the place where that most
to power minus K on any string and the
extractor gets one sample from x1 sample
from why and again for this talk I just
focus on extracting one uniform bit but
in general the goal is to extract more
bits and more formally what you would
want is that the probability that the
extract it takes value one when Sam when
you gets when you get samples from X and
Y is close to half and epsilon is called
the error parameter of the x extractor
and a simple by now standard pro elastic
method actually shows that a random
function is a good to source extractor
so a random function is a to source
extractor for sources with minh entropy
as small as login plus order one it's so
it's a source on n bits but it has
entropy just log in and the most nave
way of going through all functions would
take W exponential time to find such a
function and in computer science if you
want to officially do things you want
Polly time algorithm on this question of
explicitly constructing two source
extractors was was raised in the 80s and
so the constructions known was the first
work by sure and goldreich give an
extractor which works when both the
sources x and y have been entropy
slightly larger than n over 2 again
slightly improve the situation after 20
years using sophisticated methods from
additive comment fix and got it down to
0 point 5 minus alpha times n where
alpha is a very small universal constant
and Barbara showed how to extract when
one of the sources has entropy slightly
larger than n over 2 and the other
source is it can have very small mini
trip you like order log in
and this is for attracting one bit or no
all of these extracts almost all of them
in entropy out of the source yeah and it
remained a challenging open problem to
get an x factor by both the sources have
min entropy much smaller than say a note
even point 110 so the main result are
with David in this talk is an explicit
to source extractor which works form in
entropy poly log n where the scene our
work was 75 and the running time is poly
n over epsilon so the ideal running time
that you would want is poly n and log
when our epsilon so that's one open
problem which I would encourage people
to work on in this workshop all right
there is a very nice matrix way of
viewing to source extractor in
particular it's the truth table of the
two source x factor so so this is the
truth table you think of the rows as the
in the row index as the input of the
first source input from the first source
the column index as the input from the
second source so there are 2 power n
rose to power n columns corresponding to
each n bit string and since and the
entry corresponding to it is the output
of the extractor right so by the
property that it is a to source
extractor if you look at any 2 power K
columns and 2 / K rows then the
corresponding sub matrix that you get
roughly has equal number of zeros and
ones so it's a low discrepancy boolean
matrix and such matrix says have
applications in communication complexity
and other areas in the computer science
also there is a nice graph theoretic way
of viewing a to source extractor which
gives important objects in extremal
combinatorics called franza graphs omar
khayyam see graph is on n vertices and
it does not have any independent set or
clique of size K and the bipartite
version is that it doesn't have the
complete or empty k cross K sub graph
in 1928 fram's I showed that it does not
exist a log in over two ramps a graph on
n vertices and matching almost matching
this address using the paralytic method
showed that there exists to log in
rancho graphs on n vertices and he
posted as selling human problem to
actually construct explicitly construct
such ramsey graphs so given a to source
extractor how do we come up with a
ramsey graph well it's very easy what
you do is you have to power n nodes on
the left to power n nodes on the right
so each node on the left corresponds to
an n-bit string similarly on the right
and you think of the input from the
first source as a note on the left input
from the second source as a note on the
right and given your to source extractor
you just if it's the complete graph you
color all the edges on which the
extractor outputs 12 green all the notes
all the edges on which the extractor
outputs 0 to read and the guarantee is
that if you look at 2 power K vertices
on the Left 2 power K vertices on the
right then roughly the equal number of
red edges and green edges that's
directly from the extractor property so
and this gives you a bipartite Ramsey
graph alright and there has been a long
line of work for the last 70 years on
constructing explicit for MC graphs and
not go over all the details but um there
was some work which was lot of work was
stuck at this bound off so the optimal
the prolific bound is to log in there's
a lot of work which got stuck at two per
square root login and seminal works of
Barack it will got an exponential
improvement and our work implies us
another exponential improvement and it
gets to two power log log n power C for
some constant C so if sees one in fact
you get the adesh realistic bound and
independent work of gili cohen on to
source disperses also implies Francie
graphs so he independently achieved the
same results on Ramsey graphs
alright let's come back to actually
constructing do source extractors now
we're about 4k and the increase of
Ramsey you have the lower bound of
flogging over to be in this case what is
is the same season yep the concerning
baby slope
right but so ingredients are seeded
extractors which you have already some
of you have seen in the boot camp
slightly fancier extract is called non
malleable extractors resilient functions
and we'll look at some kind of sources
or it's so and the outline is outline of
the construction is the following that
using some extractor machinery we will
convert given a sample from x and y we
will transform it into a single source
which has these white coordinates which
are good they're independent slightly
lying there independent random bits and
red coordinates which actually depend on
these bits and then we'll use some other
machinery and some others i randomness
tools to get a uniform bit alright so
let's start off with the ingredients a
seeded extractor takes as input a week
source X which is an n comma K source
and some independent helper bits d where
d is short much shorter than m and what
you want is that the output of the
extractor is uniform and not just this
but you'd want the output of the
extractor to be uniform even conditioned
on the seed so even given the seed
output should look uniform so one could
say that since Y is already uniform you
know the extractor could just output Y
so you don't want the extractor to cheat
so that's kind of an informal way of
saying this and by a really beautiful
line of work we have seeded extractors
with which achieve almost optimal
parameters so you can extract using this
log in bets and you get almost all of
the men entropy out of your source right
and an equivalent way of presenting this
seeded extractors is the following so
what you do is you fix the seed of the
extractor so now fixing the sea to why
the extractor is now just the function
of the source X right so there are two
power D functions corresponding to each
fixing of the seed and the property of
the strong seeded extractor is the
following that there exists a large
fraction of seeds which namely 1 minus
epsilon fraction of the seeds such that
for any such fixing if we apply the
corresponding function on your source X
the output that you get output
distribution that you get is almost
close to uniform in statistical distance
so we'll always be dealing with
statistical distance in this talk all
right and next we'll need a slightly
fancier extractor it's called a non
malleable extractor which was introduced
by Doris in Vic's in cryptography but
does not present the original definition
I'll present something which is enough
of this talk and it's also equivalent so
it's called a teen on malleable
extractor and again it takes a week
source X and it takes a seat and it
outputs one bed for the shop we'll just
output one bit and the property is that
again there is a large fraction of seats
such that now if you pick any T distinct
seeds from this set and look at the
corresponding functions FY and you apply
FY on the source X then you would want
these to be independent and uniform
right so if what the Joint Distribution
of FY 1 of X through FY d of x is
actually close to uniform right so when
T is 1 this is exactly a strong seeded
extract
and it's done up that is tricky tricky
to construct these things and so in
joint work with people go Alan Shenley
we constructed these extractors which
has side length which is poly in TN poly
log N and also similar entropy and gets
almost all of the things out and there
has been a lot of work in getting the
poly factors right after this so all
right yes please t also like with like a
liquid extractors if you like um Jews
you like to like a probabilistic method
you like see like you know how well a a
random you're way stronger would you
like you always like these bounds
prepare with so good right so for the
seeded xfactor its pretty so you want
seed which is log n plus log 1 over
epsilon up two constants and even here
the dependence on epsilon is log 1 over
epsilon and 40 yeah you can show that
the seed length depends logarithm Utley
on T and the main entropy is you need to
have order like yeah this thing is off
plate but now the best known is I think
login times log log n so
and the final ingredient that will need
is resilient functions so the best way
to motivate this is through this coin
flipping game so it was introduced by
bernard and lineal and suppose you have
a bunch of n players who are flipping
coins and sending it to a trusted
authority who applies a function f to
output a bit be fair all of the players
are convinced that it sir it's an
unbiased bit so if everyone is playing
honestly and the send uniform bets f
could just pick one of the players or
apply parity to basically do anything
but the setting is much more interesting
when there are malicious coalition's of
players so these coalition's actually
wait for the other place to send their
bits and then looking at them they send
their own bits right and how do you
measure the influence of this coalition
well you say that it's the priority that
prolly do over the coin flips of the
honest players that the coalition can
coalition Q can actually change the
value of the function f right so more
formally now a resilient function is a
boolean function from n bits to one bit
and let Q be a subset of coordinates and
you sample a string X in the following
way that you sample bits outside q
uniformly and independently and leave
the bits and Q unfixed and then you look
at the function f of X which is now just
a function of the coordinates in queue
that it's not the constant function or
in other words the bits Inc you can
actually change the value of the
function so this is exactly the
influence of Q on on the function f
and a cucumber salon resilient function
is a function such that no set of Kew
Gardens can have influenced more than
epsilon on the function f so trivial
resilient function is the constant
function because any set of coordinates
cannot change the value of the function
so in this so we'll be focused on
constructing the Sicilian functions
which have bias close to one-half or its
expectation under the uniform
distribution is close to one up and for
example spell parity is not a good
resilient function because even one
coordinate can change its value and
majority can handle up to square root n
bad players great and resilient
functions are extractors for certain
kind of sources so we'll be interested
in non oblivious prefixing sources and
obf sources so here the white bits
correspond to good pets and their sample
from some distribution d which you can
even think of as uniform and independent
and the red bits they arbitrarily depend
on the values of the white pets and if
you have a function f which is q comedy
comma epsilon resilient and it's also
unbiased on the distribution d and it's
easy to see that the parity f of x is
one is close to one-half and this is
because since its bias is half and the
bits in the red coatings can at most
change the value with parity epsilon it
can bias the value of the function f of
x by at most excellent so it's so f is
an extractor for all set sources
alright so back to our program let's
let's try to execute the step NOP
yourself origin non oblivious so it's
yeah it's a bit fixing source and the
the red coordinates actually depend on
the value of the white cotton so it's
not oblivious it's not obvious
alright so a preliminary attempt suppose
we just get a good strong synod
extractor so recall that for a strong
synod xfactor dicks so let X be the
first source to the two source extractor
right it gets a sample and the idea is
run over all the seeds of the extractor
well since we have really good
constructions of strong fitted
extractors where these order log in the
total number of seeds is poly n right so
just run over all the seats and so
corresponding to each seed since X
Factor just outputs one bit the IH
coordinate of this long string
corresponds to the extractor run on the
IH seed right it gets one sample from X
and runs over all the seeds right so you
brute force over all this it's it's
important that you do not get a uniform
seed you brute force over all the seeds
and the property that we saw of strong
sintered extractors is that the output
is close to uniform for most seats right
so for 1 minus epsilon fraction of this
string their uniform that's almost
uniform bits and the red bits are not
uniform and they arbitrarily depend on
these white pizza so it seems like
they're pretty close to maybe extracting
that's because there are a lot of
uniform beds there so maybe taking the
majority of these bits could give you a
uniform bed but it does not fit because
the uniform bets there in deep with
their uniform on their own but they may
be arbitrarily correlated you do not
know what's going on there so so it's
it's not clear why majority should work
here a second attempt is to get most
structure in those uniform bits to make
them almost device-independent and the
tool for this seeing the definition of a
teen on malleable extractor it's just
that now take a non malleable extractor
get a sample from X and run the non
malleable extractor on all its seeds
right now thus length of this string is
actually kwasi poly but say we don't
care maybe we are happy with just an to
source extractor which works in Kwazii
poly time so we brew force over all
these seeds and now you know that this
white
bits they're all almost
device-independent right this lot of
structure in them and the red bits there
are at most epsilon fraction of them and
they arbitrarily depend on the white
bits oh yeah how do we know it's an
epsilon fraction don't we just know this
like an epsilon fraction of T two bolts
that are bad no so you can actually
prove its it's fairly simple to show
that there's actually so the way I
defined it was that there's this set of
1 minus epsilon fraction of you know
seed such that if you pick any T
distinct tuples from there let's so you
cannot all right so now one could prolly
apply majority and use D randomized
central limit theorem to probably try to
get random bits out of this but the
problem is that there are just too many
40 bits so epsilon times 3 which is the
fraction of bad bits is much greater
than square root d which is roughly what
you get from the central limit theorem
but actually you could replace majority
with more resilient functions to get
over this but the real problem is that
these wide-based are almost device
independent and if you go to a
device-independent distribution you add
too much error so anything which is
greater than one is meaningless here so
this thing doesn't work and it's good
that it doesn't work because still no we
have just used one source so and we know
that there cannot exist are one source
extract so the idea is now to use the
second source to compress this string
and the way to compress it is to project
it to a pseudo random set of coordinates
and this by now is standard in the
extractor literature is to use a sampler
unfortunately we just have another week
source wife which we haven't used so far
but it's it's it's not haha but by work
of devs ackerman we actually know how to
sample using week sources so the idea is
you take a seeded extractor whose output
would actually each output would
correspond to a coordinate in the string
right so why is now the second source
which finally appears take a strong
cited exceeded X Factor run it over all
its seeds so now note that em since a
seeded extractors seed length is order
log n the number of seeds is Polly n so
you run over all its seeds and
corresponding to the output of each seed
we get an index of the coordinate in
this long string right so throw away all
the other coordinates now we are left
with a projection which is as Polly and
in size and note that actually the if'
bit in this is the non malleable
extractor on X with the seed as
extractor of Y comma ri right so to get
the string you don't actually have to
run all the non valuable extractor all
you got to do is use the CD extractor
with the second source to choose the
seeds and then run the non valuable
extractor on it so now we end up with a
source which is poly and in size and the
number of faulty bits with calculation
you can show this little of em so it's
actually empower point 99 for some Delta
and why is this the case well because
now on a very informal level what you
have done is the length M no longer
depends on the error epsilon which was
from the non valuable extractor so you
can push epsilon down and get this to
the right fraction all right so now
after all this we can essentially forget
we have all we have we had two sources
and just focus on extracting from this
source which we have developed now so
let's go to the second part of the
construction oh it's so fresh start you
have a string V on n bits the white pets
they are sampled from a
device-independent distribution so if
you look at any T coordinates and
project them then they are almost
independent and uniform so T is poly log
in the number of red bits is n power
point 99 and this red bits arbitrarily
depend on the values of the white Mets
right and we have seen that this is
exactly the kind of sources for which
resilient functions are extractors right
so and the resilient function that will
construct will be a low depth circuit
see Sean can you can you call it in
which there was it the previous step
discounting step where the error has to
be one of a polynomial that's the step
was accounting stuff that you can push
up slow down each step there oh you mean
here the calculation yeah these are this
devilish things are to be in this
polynomial of each step I mean reaches a
critical step by inverse paranormal
Canada right so uh so the non malleable
extractor can have its ok so the major
bottleneck is using the resilient
function which is the second step
because they're just k KL or it shows
that you cannot go below below the
length of the string and since we are
working with strings of poly length you
cannot have less than one yes like I
guess M is M divided by epsilon Prime
and I guess it means at epsilon prime
cannot be like exponential oh its
financial all right I mean even he it
looks like you you you should yeah all
right so yeah exactly yeah you cannot
have it Sun Prairie just
okay so now we are trying to extract
from these kind of sources where these
bits are t-vice independent and the
first step that we do here is translate
into a slightly easier problem where
we'll say that these white bits instead
of being device independent they're
actually uniform so this is a big step
because there are n minus little o of n
white bits and they were only poly log
base in independent before but we are
saying it's enough to solve the problem
when their uniform and this this step is
through a easy but need observation
which says that if the resilient
function is of a certain kind then you
can actually solve just this problem and
reduce it to the other problem so the
idea is this let's suppose the resilient
function is actually monotone then you
can actually check if the good bits
after sampling the good bits the
functions value the value of the
resilient function is already fixed or
not right and the way to do it is set
all the bits in the coalition q 2 zeros
all the bits in the coalition q2 once
and check if they are the same output
now since see is a monotone function if
at all the coordinates in q could
actually change the value of the
function then these both have to be
different right because it's monitor and
note that if C is a low depth circuit
then C prime is also a low depth circuit
right so what we have seen is that the
probability that you can actually change
the value when the white bits are
sampled from some distribution D is
exactly the expected value of this
circuit C prime that we constructed with
the not equals thing right so now the
idea is to invoke the seminal result of
Braverman on small depth circuits which
says that T wise independence fools um
low depth circuits are in the in other
sense it cannot distinguish between
uniform and device independence so but
it essentially says is that if C prime
is a low depth circuit and the expected
value of C Prime under t wise
independent distribution is
close to when the good bits are sample
from a uniform distribution right so
let's translates into saying that the
influence that a coalition has when the
good bits are device-independent is
close to the influence it has when the
good bits are uniform so this is the
reduction most monotonicity na c 0 so
you need both both low depth and
monotonicity and first getting such
getting hold of such functions it turns
out that ideally Neil got is pretty
close but there are some problems right
there lineal constructed a pluralistic
construction of low depth circuits so
they cuts their construction was roughly
this that they took a tribe function so
a try base or of ants on disjoint sets
of variables so each is a block if a
plot unanimously says one then the tribe
says the tribe function is 1 and
corresponding to how you partition these
n coordinates you get different tribes
so what I'd a lineal the idea linear
function looks like this that it
randomly partitions it takes n random
partitions and corresponding to them
looks at the tribes function that you
get they also randomly negative area
Buhl's and then take an end of all these
stripe functions so it's a pluralistic
construction that's a problem and it's
also not monotone but the good thing is
that they show that there exists
functions in this realistic space which
which are resilient of coalition's of
size n over log square n so it's we need
just resilience up to n power point 99
but this is even beyond that so the
polyps there is no more than ECT I mean
what you drew is one of them but i guess
the renegade so we are so yeah rihanna
cases here so the name d randomization
of going through all partitions and all
negations should take an over order n
square time and further it's not fun at
all so our main contribution here is 2d
randomized aight aight linear and also
remove the monotonicity things and the
key ingredient at least one of the key
ingredients is coming up with a pseudo
random collection of partitions because
each partition gives you are tribes
function so the
the properties that we roughly need from
the partition are that so we have a
bunch of partitions and partitions say
and we need that for any small subset so
for any point 99 set of coordinates it
has to have small intersection with most
partitions and by intersection with the
partition I mean intersection with each
block of the partition so any small
subset should have small intersection
with each block of the partition and we
need a lot of such partitions and this
is used to bound the influence of this
exactly this set of coordinates and
further we also need a design kind of
property that the partition should be so
if you look at any block of a partition
and any other block of any other
partition then they should have limited
intersection so it's kind of a design
property and this is actually used to
show that the function that we construct
has bias close to half and at the
uniform distribution which turns out to
be tricky and the way we construct these
partitions is again using extract seeded
extractors so roughly recall that seeded
extractors are samplers so if you look
at the graph of a seeded extractor that
is the week source input corresponds to
the left node the output of the seeded
extractor is on the right and there is a
an edge between them if some seed takes
the input to the output and we call as
an input X bad correspond with respect
to a settee statistical test e if the
neighbors over hit this settee and it
was shown by soccer man that the number
of such access is bounded by 2 power K
where K is the entropy for which the
x-factor works so it somehow is related
to the first property where we do not
want too many things to intersect have
large intersection with a small set but
it's far from trivial to see how this
can be used to get partitions so so this
slide is a very generic statement about
how to you know get partitions from
a slightly simpler problem what are the
parameters the partition say what is the
size of each parent can go so the block
length is like logon
so suppose you want to partition em and
say n is M times B where is a beast like
login and suppose you have a collection
of sets s 1 through s are so that
they're small sets their login size sets
and each si looks like 1 comma I 1
through become I be where I one I
through I be our numbers from 1 to M
right so the claim is that using each si
you can actually come up with a
partition and the way to do it is this
that think of si as a line here right
and by shifting this line looking at all
the shifts you get you cover this space
of n right so each SI defines a
partition and then you get FR partition
so if you want to partition and if you
want a lot of partitions of n one way is
to come up with the small sets and then
shift them and the way we come up with
this small sets is looking at the graph
of the seeded extractor and
corresponding to each left node we
define the neighbors to be the essays so
this gives you are partitions and the
the properties that we needed from the
partitions translates to properties of
this graph the first property is the
limited intersection property which is
fairly direct from the sampler view of
the extractor the second is a design
property which look at every sense
extractor actually satisfies we prove
this so using these things we come up
with the partitions and so the main
ingredients are the pseudo-random
partitions we show a new way of
analyzing the bias of the italian 'i'll
function which is actually crucial in
showing that you don't need to negate
variables and it's you get a mano a mano
rhone function alright so applying these
things this on this source you get the
uniform bit there has been a lot lot of
subsequent work with a lot of new ideas
old techniques which gets the minion
trippy requirement so obvious was locked
for 75 and this now the best work is
some constant times log log constant and
slog in times long long again Shin
showed how to extract more bets
there has been progress exciting
progress on a lot of different other
kinds of sources which were stuck for
some time where who improved our
resilient function Raghu maker and one
problem which would be really nice to
solve this achieving small error waist
chains oh yeah what a scar yeah I think
you mentioned that by gum simply assume
the movie any mention how simply is
silly wait on actually I think I mean
anyway no I can't remember how I was
gonna sr ok so let's say thank you shine
maybe 15 minutes a break